so um you want to talk about vegas or
what happened uh
yeah i like the story i like how you
think that i
set you up for destruction because okay
so
bobby calls me in the middle of the day
uh i remember this very specifically
because i just got done shooting like a
music video in venice
and he calls me he's like hey man what
are you doing tomorrow
i was like i i don't know i got like a
show around here locally in la but
that's about it what's up he goes
you want to go to vegas
and i go what yes
you don't go to vegas with papa yeah
that's the way he asked yeah and i was
like like for like for like for a show
like yeah daddy's got a private
corporate gig
i need you to open for me yeah i was
like okay great and he goes
all right meet me tomorrow my place pick
me up and then we're gonna go rent a car
and then we'll drive to vegas i was like
okay cool
so we go to the the rental place he
fills out
all the paperwork and we're looking at
all the cars and then he like
tosses me keys like an 80s movie
i catch him and he's like that's us over
there yeah
did that make you drive yeah you know
you're not the way yeah of course i did
yeah you're on your ipad the whole time
it's beautiful yeah
and uh it was a brand new dodge
challenger
and it was like
really a much faster car than we needed
like by any means yeah
and we go to vegas and uh we have a good
time like bobby's take it to dinner
you dude i mean thank you for that i
remember the picture of that steak
the steak was ridiculous because they
were a fan of bobby and they're like i'm
gonna get you
prime cut and jus we couldn't even
finish the meat yeah yeah
and i being you know his poor opener i'm
like can i take some of this to go
bobby will not let you take
the amount of why why though you're like
i paid for it
that's mine because people i tell that
story sometimes and people don't believe
me
yeah the amount of meals that that i
wanted to take with bobby but that's
never crazy
but you just leave it but then you go
you really want that
you really want that dude yeah just take
some money just go get a new meal
okay get a new meal i know i'm such a
gross person
though hearing it though yeah right it
makes me feel like why do i behave that
way
so um and this is good this is a good
thing so then what happens so we have a
great time like
just like on the way we get some meals
and stuff like that and
i remember at the check-in counter we
had a room like
at this amazing suite at the window at
the win
yeah like it was it was like this
amazing spread i'd never seen a hotel
like this in my life
i'm from kansas i'm like i'm in vegas
right now with bobby like this is crazy
and uh we checking at the counter and uh
he's like hey man uh
reservation for bobby lee and uh he was
like oh welcome mr lee and uh
he looked at the guy at the counter he's
like uh we're gonna we're gonna go [ __ ]
each other in that room
and as a joke though as a joke as a joke
you know bobby does live like
yeah yeah yeah that thing yeah yeah
and uh and and i like go into it i go
along with it because i yes and
everything
like yeah like yeah man i i'm gonna suck
his dick and bobby didn't like that i
played along with it
because bobby likes to be the weirdest
person in the room
he gets mad when somebody out weirds him
yeah yeah he gets really upset
i do he's like hey he's like yeah i'm
gonna [ __ ] his butt like
like he had the uh
yeah so we check into this room
and uh i tell bobby i'm like uh oh can
we take
can we take like some some promo photos
and he's like yeah sure
and uh and so he has his shirt off and i
start to take my shirt off and he goes
whoa whoa whoa whoa what are you doing
like i was i was gonna join in with you
you know promo photos yeah
nah man that's me you're the opener
keep your shirt on he's like he's very
much likes to put me
in my place like i like our entire
friendship i feel bad
it's okay but finish the story so we go
to this gig
later in the evening and it's for
an all-male crowd
literally at the top of the show it's
it's like a before bobby
it's a men's like it's a billionaire
men's club
yeah and it's like you know a bunch of
businessmen
and millionaires right and i don't know
why you would think that they would hire
bert kreischer
or somebody of that elk right but for
some reason
they wanted me and so we go into this
and also in this room right it's not
just a showroom
it's it's a gigantic like warehouse
looking like a place right like it's a
conventional ballroom
ballroom right huge ballroom and then
it's like the other half of the ballroom
is curtained off
for an auction so there's like sports
cars in there and like memorabilia you
know i mean yeah
and people are you know in
in in the place where we're performing
people are there but
also people are out bidding and walking
around in this other area
so there's it's and and we're supposed
to perform for just the front part
yeah in this environment it's almost
like performing in front of a cafeteria
yeah right because it was like there was
no show almost what it felt like
it felt like a nightmare it was it was
one of the hardest gigs
i've had i've never seen
anybody bomb
as bad as jeremiah i mean i've seen
thousands of shows right but here's what
i loved about it
it's like you know when you bought like
i've seen openers
bomb and cry or they they start off
strong
but delete the crowd you know i mean
wither them down into nothing
right and when i see that happening i
feel sad all right
but when i see what jeremiah did right
it makes me proud like a proud parent
what this [ __ ] guy got
he goes up there and people there are
guys
standing up
with red-faced veins on their faces
right this is 100 percent true
yeah 100 true get off
you suck get off get off
the stage yeah oh my god
screaming screaming you know now worried
about neighbors
oh yeah yeah that but that's but
literally
literally that's in the first 40 seconds
yeah oh sh right and i'm in the back
like
through a curtain looking at him right
and when i'm hearing get off
jeremiah is on stage upside down
with a stool or something right in a
post
pole and he's doing some sort of like
physical drink
some
he does not care right he does how much
three minutes no you said you said this
is what you said right before i went on
yeah because you had to do 40 minutes
for this course
oh my god you do 40 minutes and you go
you go
all right
[Laughter]
i need you to do uh seven minutes and if
you want to make daddy real happy do
more like 10.
all right yeah okay and before i went
out there they'd just done a raffle
they just in a raffle yeah and then the
guy the host
he gets handed a card and he goes oh
i guess i guess the the act brought
an opener oh my god
this is my intro i guess the act brought
an opener yeah
uh please welcome
jeremiah he doesn't even say yeah yeah
please welcome jeremiah jeremiah
and i walk out nobody claps nobody claps
because they want to see bobby
so what bobby knew was gonna happen
is that i was gonna be the sacrificial
lamb for that gig
i ate it too no you didn't no you didn't
i
not as hard as you bobby you're doing
that thing you're doing that thing
you did no no no no no no no doing that
i did okay
because i remember him saying he crushed
it
but to preface this on the on the way to
vegas the entire time
bobby is telling me you're gonna bond
tonight oh i love that one you're gonna
bomb have i done you before my first
time doing stuff
uh you actually did on this podcast for
three weeks and promoting yeah yeah yeah
so and i was like no i'm not no i'm not
you're you're like you'll see
you'll see and then it happened the only
laugh i heard the entire time
was bobby dying laughs backstage just
cackling
because it was so he thought it was so
funny to see what
was happening just the absolute nothing
that i was getting from the ground
i know but i wasn't laughing at the
because you're failing
i was laughing at the fact that you're
seeing two different things at the same
time yeah of course
you're seeing hatred like literally like
you know um imagine like um
aoc going to a trump rally yeah that's
what it felt like
yeah like just the wrong person at the
wrong time
right and then aoc committing right
to a speech right and finishing it
like doubling like i'm gonna i have a 10
minute speech i'm in a trump rally
and i'm gonna finish it now imagine
aoc saying good night
and then trump walking out kicking her
in the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and saying
[Laughter]
and literally after the show like you
know they're cutting the check and stuff
and they're like wow that's amazing
everybody's coming up them shaking his
hand one picture
and i'm just standing there like looking
for anything the entire time just
looking for any reassurance and
uh the booker kept looking at me and
going yeah kid good luck
uh yeah but then bobby he knew what had
happened he took me out to like the
nicest steak dinner afterwards and
reward me like dude you did exactly why
i brought you here you did exactly what
i wanted to do because i'm going to tell
you something all right
if he hadn't gone up before me and done
that
i would have struggled for 15 minutes of
course yeah right yeah i knew so i
needed a kid
right that was going to commit to it
right
was going to know he was going to fail
right
and set me up and i'm going to say this
right now
it sounds cruel but i had been
that guy of course right jay moore did
it to me
at usc right we had a daytime show
right it was supposed to start at five
right
and i was supposed to do 15 minutes but
i'm i'm i'm in my 15 minutes and and i
was like
about to wrap up but the sun was still
up and jaymore goes
you're not getting off stage until the
sun is
yeah i mean gone until it sets
until it's black oh geez right
and i remember being up there for an
hour and a half
yeah eating it just running around
i did everything i could every trick
that i had in the
running around you know everyone claps
sing a song right i was doing everything
right
and i bombed so bad and i got off stage
so angry off stage so angry
and then jay went up you know i mean
everyone cheered he killed it
and i just remember just being in a ball
of anger
in the back but then in retrospect i go
i thought you know that's just the best
you know
ex comedy experience that you can have
because it's like you're learning to
perform
right like when you're on the tonight
show
and you're bombing right if you're
if you've condem conditioned yourself to
pretend
that you're doing well in a hostile
environment right
people on the camera watching it are
going to go oh he's doing fine
right it's if you let the audience
affect you
right then you're dead and that's why i
think the comedy store
store is so important because it's such
a tough room
right yeah that we're able to learn how
to that's right
when you play the comedy store and then
you go to a place like the ice house
it's easy it's it's like
you're killing it right but um i think
that
you know putting young comics in those
kind of
you know environments is a good thing in
the beginning of all this
you said that in vegas he [ __ ] you
so it was the other way around i did
[ __ ] him
you [ __ ] him i [ __ ] you yeah i did i
[ __ ] you and i apologize
yeah it's okay man but look at you now i
i know i'm here with you
no i know i did but no it's not that bro
i've been we freaking made it dude i
want to say something okay
when i watch you when i watch you on
tony hinchcliffe's
show what's a kill tony yeah
right it's and i watch you improvise
into different characters and
and do your thing i think i literally
always think to myself
wow that guy is so funny i really do hey
guys we're going to take a really quick
break to share one of our favorite
sponsors with
you him himself if you need it you're
going to need it
him tim's him if you're a man you're
gonna want
it yeah